if you're 18 years old in two days you  could go and become certified as a  phlebotomist and go from making 750 or  whatever the minimum wage is to what  phlebotomists make at 25 an hour you  would triple your earning capacity after  two days and spending 500 do you think  it's worth the investment probably  there's the value of the problem that  you solve and what you charge for it the  bigger that number is the more you can  charge that gap between their old  problem and the solution is the  percentage that you can take and put in  your pocket as something that you have  now created in this and it could be a  service it could be products it could be  whatever your earning capacity is going  to be the thing that generates you  wealth